I can't turn on the TV and I'll scan
around a lot and I'm constantly running
into the Beverly Hills 90210 reruns and
I'm thinking what is that like for you
now you know I know you're married
you've got kids you don't watch I don't
I I we have sort of a strict policy in
our house if we don't watch each other
stuff
my wife will kind of try and sneak it in
every once in a while and see see your
wife obviously the level you Meaghan
[ __ ] she likes to watch 902 103 well she
doesn't it she doesn't like to watch it
necessarily it's more you know just to
kind of make fun of me sort of that
seems very cool it's well it does seem
cruel but it's in a fun it's in a fun
way we sort of found that our
relationship works the best if we do
that right now if we kind of don't take
it too seriously well also it's also
probably the different looks because
there are some iconic early 90s you'll
know yes I was I was in New York many
many you have on the show many times
back in the day and and we had I
remembered some of these that we were
looking at photos today danger on his
collar
this is your phase for you a for a
physicist I think for a lad
that's my headshot oh I like the dog
that dog died and then that's guy that's
good I'm curious about something that
was my special Conan shooting member
that that was just for me it was just a
t-shirt run we did it really quick you
sold out of him fastest I had to have I
saw them and I had to have them you and
I are alone you and I are alone I want
to see you in one of those t-shirts wear
that t-shirt I come out I'm gonna bring
yeah yeah I wear it around town you and
I are rare commodities in TV because
both of us have made the transition from
nerdy guy to hunky guy right this man
had his own blimp when the show started
you you uh it's it's it's interesting
because when I know to when I first
started you were awesome yeah awesome
right but also sort of cast as like the
nerdy character and then later on you're
on Desperate Housewives as the homina
homina homina guy right that's a pretty
hard transition to make yeah yeah
it's a lot of pressure I actually it was
the easier to be the nerdy guy than to
be way easier
I've never that's the only thing I've
ever done where I was I found myself
doing push-ups like between takes and
that's not my thing I'm not like a gym
guy I you know I like that I'm not one
of those like guys that worked out in
the gym but it was you know I had to put
the work in there right because every
time you're on keeps you're on camera
that a shirt and that's why I I was a
contractor and apparently all
contractors are very fit they walk
around with your clothes on yeah even if
you're going to the bank you have no
shirt on right exactly